foreign
I'm calling out Ben Affleck for a sucky
advertisement I was hoping you would say
I'm calling out LeBron James
I wouldn't even agree with you but I
would have to be silent because I would
just want you to criticize LeBron and
enjoy hearing you criticize at this
point anyway anyway for today
and let's take a look at this video I
want to call out Ben Affleck
welcome to Dunkin a new special Duncan
run medium large coffee get a donut for
an incremental dollars like how can it
be this inexpensive and good pretty no
sugar I'm just gonna have to just give
you 10 munchkins you look a little lost
one second I'm trying to find the bagels
do I look familiar yeah
should I be in it or do you want it
that's what you do when you say you're
going to work all day I gotta go guys
grab me a glaze
so I don't have a problem
at least it was funny no that's the
problem the problem is this is a good
commercial it is an effective commercial
but what are they doing here it is a
good commercial that is selling diabetes
it's selling obesity and it is selling
disease and so I wouldn't have a problem
with Ben Affleck doing a Toyota
commercial or a Lexus commercial or a
vacuum commercial things that are useful
to people Dunkin Donuts however is
delicious but it's delicious because
they make the foods hyper palatable and
they make the foods addictive and
because the foods are addictive and then
we couple it with someone we admire one
of the best actors and directors of Our
Generation it makes it not just hyper
palatable to your palate but hyper
palatable to your psyche and so when we
see these so celebrities participating
in advertisements that are actively
harmful to the populace that keep us
unhealthy diseased overweight and they
they make our lives miserable and so
this is increasing the misery of
humanity why do you do something like
that when a you don't need to do it but
B it also makes you look like you aren't
the person who you are it makes you look
like you aren't one of the best actors
and directors and writers of a
generation this is Beneath You Ben
um
yeah it's unfortunate it is unfortunate
go ahead you know what I'm gonna do
you know I'm gonna be Angel's advocate
for a second
good luck find an angel in this one he's
gonna bring a Michael Jordan and
McDonald's
because he's triggering me because I'm
thinking about the Jordan commercial and
I'm being defensive no I'm just kidding
no I'm I'm actually I'm genuinely
curious it's probably going to sound
like um trying to needle you but I
really want to know your answer to this
um
I know you say you don't take a moral
stance on it
that sounds to me like a moral stance
I'm not accusing you of being a
hypocrite sure I want you to reconcile
that for me because
it sounds like there there's a and
there's nothing wrong with a moral
standing stance in my opinion but it
sounds like there's some should involved
in there that like there's a hierarchy
of value like he's doing something
that's beneath him that that they're
basically selling poison or selling
diabetes they're doing something
unhealthy and then on top of that
they're taking advantage of people in
this way it feels like a moral stance if
it's not
what is it why am I saying it like that
I'm grossed out that's what it is I'm
truly grossed out when I see someone
who's such a great actor who's a great
director writer just a brilliant artist
doing something like this
I see it and I'm like
why why would you do it not because I
think it's immoral to do this I don't
think it's immoral I think it's gross I
think doing advertisements like this
it's beneath us it's certainly beneath a
savant
like Ben Affleck I mean this guy is a
Mozart of acting and yet
that's what makes us even more
pernicious because it's not just a
random stand in selling us
sugar-coated delicious diabetes it's
someone that people look up to and I'm
just grossed out by it man yeah for me
it makes me think of uh when the Tiger
Woods Saga really unfolded and how he
was he was a Serial cheater and things
like I really looked up to Tiger Woods
and then I saw how he you know treated
his wife and family and yeah I was
grossed out and it's like I can still
appreciate his golf game but I do see
what you're saying man like it sounds
like you really look up to Ben Affleck
and then he does something like this and
you're like why you're one of my role
models like why would you do this yeah
yeah I don't look up to him as a human
being I look up to him as an artist and
when and of course I can decouple the
artist from the art that they do but to
me this is just putting a turd in the
soup and like if you have one of the
best chefs you know if you have Chef
Ramsay right Gordon Ramsay and then you
make is delicious stew for you and then
he just comes over and puts one turd in
it it ruins the whole stew I don't know
man you haven't tried my turds too
and so here's a question for you guys my
wife and I were talking about this the
other day
um
like franchise ownership and and I know
you guys if you were interested in
owning a bunch of franchises you would
already do that but let's assume that
you were would you experience a conflict
with something like owning a Duncan
franchise or a McDonald's franchise that
sells something you think is unhealthy
I'll I'll take my own personal
experience here so Ryan and I own a
coffee house called Bandit coffee in St
Petersburg Florida and you'll never see
me post anything we only own 40 of the
coffee house but you'll never see me
post anything that I don't
100 percent believe believe it and so
like if they have some sort of delicious
looking Donut for the day because they
have some vendor who came in I don't
like that and if it were 100 my my shop
there's no way that I would tolerate
that or allow that and I'm still grossed
out in fact I'm grossed out by it even
more because I have something to do with
this shop and so it makes me want to
uncouple myself from that even because
it's not a moral stance but for me it's
beneath me to recommend something that I
don't 100 believe in
we could do a whole episode sometime
we're getting a whole bunch of these
whole episodes thank you but on like
moral and aesthetic value like hierarchy
of value like um maybe the difference
between saying I'm disgusted by X versus
I think X is objectively morally morally
wrong or objectively immoral
and and just how our value system
um affects our our lives and so forth
you know like the tiger thing for me
that's a moral issue
um yeah yeah that's different yeah I see
what you're saying and I think well the
tiger thing is both moral and not moral
like because he was also a for
Buick and all these other places right
and the question becomes like
why I I and
it's a genuine question I have like why
I understand if
some random guy you know if Jeff Woods
is in the Buick commercial it's so he
can earn a living and I don't begrudge
anyone for that and by the way I defend
Ben Affleck's right to be in this gross
commercial right I'm not saying he
shouldn't be in it in fact if someone
were to jump up and say it should be
illegal for actors to be in commercials
I would say no I'm grossed out by these
commercials but absolutely not I don't
want to put a moratorium on that Jordan
you had uh something to say real quick
yeah uh I just I'd be remiss if I didn't
add the the back story on this uh about
Ben Affleck and his involvement with
Dunkin Donuts from the beginning of his
career and the fact that he's from
Boston and Duncan is like a big deal in
Boston yeah he's always he actually
loves the brand and always has it it's
like ridiculous how he he is like a
champion for them with even without
being a sponsor and then like I was
actually just seen a post yesterday of
like 15 pictures in a row of him he
literally like lives Dunkin Donuts and
his first role in his first movie was
Goodwill Hunting in his first scene he
delivered a cup of Dunkin Donuts to to
will so oh that's great there's a little
bit of like it's not totally like a
random brand deal I would say it was a
little bit a little like I don't know if
that that doesn't help his situation in
this regard but I just I I had to
include that isn't it I think that it
makes it worse and I'll I'll say why
really quickly because people associate
Dunkin Donuts with Greater Boston
specifically New England generally right
and then they associate him with Boston
especially Goodwill Hunting and so what
you're doing is you're associating a
piece of art
with a consumer brand imagine if and by
the way I don't think we're that far off
from this one of my favorite books is
Infinite Jest and each chapter title is
a year and they've replaced the years
with corporate sponsors and so it's no
longer 2017 it is the year of the depend
adult undergarment way as part of the
writing as like as part of it as part of
the world that it's in so we're no
longer in 2017 or 2023 now we are in the
year of the depend adult undergarment I
gotta read that yes but you know it's
I'm sorry are we finished what's
interesting is like
um first off I love donuts like I don't
eat donuts all the time
um I can't even tell you the last time I
had a donut but there's nothing wrong
with
the donut there's nothing wrong with
Dunkin Donuts for me
um the point that I'm gathering from you
Josh is like he is basically encouraging
people to eat more Donuts but that's not
I don't feel like that's on Ben that's
on our own individual choice I mean the
freedom that we have we could eat
Twinkies for every single meal if we
wanted to that's our choice
um yeah I don't know I'm kind of torn on
it I do see the grossness of it that
you're talking about but yeah it's it's
just interesting because I don't blame
Ben for diabetes
yeah this is interesting to me because
the easy conversation for me to have and
I know it's not an easy conversation for
everyone but the easy the easy direction
for me to take the conversation is is a
legal one where I defend the right of
people like Ben Affleck to make
commercials for whoever he wants to make
it for and say you know I don't think
anybody has the right to shut that down
right to kind of make that sort of
argument but you know there there is a
moral issue too right like just because
something is legal or or maybe shouldn't
be made illegal doesn't mean that um
that it's good uh that doesn't mean that
it's morally good or that has a positive
benefit on society and there's more to
thinking about human responsibility
there's more to thinking about making
the world better than just in terms of
what ought to be legal versus illegal
thousands of legal things we can do that
harm people yeah
um and we should look at those things so
it's interesting to me uh for those
reasons but I'm more inclined in your
direction I enjoy a good cup of Duncan
coffee
um and you know
I enjoy a good donut you know um I don't
know when the last time I ate at Dunkin
specifically uh but
yeah for me I I like the story that
Jordan shared I think it's kind of a
cool fun thing but but I will be
interested in having more conversation
too about
um how much should how much of these
advertisements actually affect our our
Behavior yeah and I'm not saying it like
I don't think they do but but I know you
said to me one time that kind of like in
the corporate world it's like they pour
a certain amount of money in there and
they don't really know how how much
right there's a way you said it that was
basically like uh back in the corporate
days like marketing knew that 50 of
their marketing worked but they couldn't
tell you which 50 it was yeah yeah
like how many people are because they're
watching these commercials they're going
out and eating more Donuts than they
would have eaten uh if it was just a
place that's there that's that's
interesting this is just me and TK
projecting our uh guilt and judgment
that we're feeling for eating Donuts you
want to go grab a donut after this man
let's do it
well I failed you all I'm sorry no man
this was fun I like this
I I always say because I feel like this
more than any other segment comes up for
me as a space where
I want to get to know you guys a little
more at how you think about these things
because I do come at it from a very
different vantage point and I'm super
curious about your philosophies on these
things and
I feel like this is one of the shorter
segments and every single time we get to
these I'll just filled with questions
and I feel like I would just love a
whole show with you guys on Advertising
I would love to maybe just interview
y'all we don't even have to debate but
just the people that I look up to I mean
I just get disappointed by the you would
never see Tom York in a Dunkin Donuts
Commercial right right
um and you never see him make music you
wouldn't even hear one of his songs in a
Dunkin Donuts Commercial yeah now they'd
be happy to pay him millions of dollars
to put you know Karma Police in there or
whatever but he would never do it and I
asked that same question why the same
reason I asked why is Ben Affleck in
this I ask myself why wouldn't Tom York
do this you know why wouldn't you see
Daniel Day-Lewis in a Dunkin Donuts
Commercial right it's interesting why
yeah I uh Roger Waters Pink Floyd
um yeah he has
told many stories about advertisers try
to get hit their music in in their uh to
get Pink Floyd's music in their
advertisements and um he has the same
stance that you're talking about right
now he's like no I refuse to like be
part of this system yeah this market and
it doesn't mean he's against money right
he'd be happy if they just wanted to
come and hand him money but not use his
songs yeah that's fine if an Advertiser
wants to come give us money but not have
us advertised for them I'm happy to take
that money sure but otherwise
you can hold on to it you made me think
of a Denzel Washington uh talked about
how in early in his career he was
offered this role and the role was not
really consistent with the way he wanted
to be seen but it would get his foot in
the door and it would definitely give
him a lot more exposure than he had and
he calls Sydney Poitier and Sydney
Poitier told him those first few roles
that you say yes to they're gonna shape
the way people see you for the rest of
your career and it might be worth saying
no to some things early on that might
give you more exposure for the sake of
preserving your integrity and having
some control over your brand and so he
said that he turned that role down and
he chose to take roles that reflected
how he wanted to represent himself in
the world how he wanted to represent the
image of a black man which is why you
don't see Denzel do training day until
much later on in his career but prior to
that he's a lawyer in Philadelphia right
he's uh in Crimson Tide he's he's an
attorney he's a doctor he's all of these
upstanding role goals and then he does
something like Training Day where he
plays this this evil character
um but he can kind of get away with it
and there is something to be said about
thinking very critically and very
carefully about what do I represent yeah
because I I can always do something for
the money but but am I am I upholding
the values that I stand for in this
world when I take that check that's an
important thing to consider you're
showing the difference here between
Denzel and Ben by the way because Denzel
also wouldn't be in that
commercial for Dunkin Donuts and what's
important to to look at here is there
are plenty of commercials that Ben
Affleck would refuse to be in he agrees
to be in a Dunkin Donuts Commercial
because it's commonly acceptable but he
wouldn't be in a Fleshlight commercial
but why flashlight's way less harmful
than Dunkin Donuts it's not even close
well I think but I do agree with
Jordan's story though I think there's a
personal connection I don't know if he's
gonna do
76 gas station commercials
no that's not what I'm talking about
though what I'm saying is if there was a
personal connection even to Fleshlight
for some reason
he wouldn't do it because it's not
acceptable by Society to do something
like that and what I'm saying is well
what's what's the difference yeah in
fact there is a difference it's that
Dunkin Donuts causes far more disease
dis ease and dysfunction and obesity and
unhealth in our society than a
Fleshlight yes yeah and so I think
that's important to keep in mind he's
still willing to say no somewhere he
draws the line somewhere and the
interesting question I don't have an
answer to that's why I'm asking this why
why why why would Denzel not do it and
why would Ben Affleck do it why would
one person say no to that what does it
take
to be a Denzel
and then what do you give up by being
Ben Affleck
um I I want to ask Ben Affleck himself
so Ben Affleck I would love to have you
on this show and I love to talk with you
about the Duncan commercials your
history in Boston and why you chose to
do this commercial and what would be
your response to the express Sentiments
of jfm TK at the minimalist emailed me
my brother I love to talk to you love
your word did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free